you love python I know you love python
now I love the Mainframe and the
Mainframe loves python as well so give
me just a few minutes and I'm going to
explain why your love of python will
translate to your love of the Mainframe
as well
here we go let's say you're a data
scientist as a data scientist you care
about more data and fast processing
well let's think about it the Mainframe
today has 70 percent of the world
structured data at least on the system
so you have access to large amounts of
very important data that run banking
systems Insurance systems the financial
World using python the python you're
used to current versions of python the
most popular python packages that you
use for data science are available
on the Mainframe as well so you can use
your skill your knowledge and you can
apply it to all of this data
and for fast we have the telom processor
the telom processor allows you to load
those models into the system and allow
them to run alongside the existing
processing so your job make sure fraud
detection happens well I can do that in
line as part of the processing I don't
have to wait I don't have to call out to
some other system it's inline processing
and I can do it as fast as a credit card
swipe so as a data scientist I use all
of my existing tools all of my existing
capability and I get access and faster
now let's turn to the next person the
SRE
when I think about sres you're using
python today you're doing infrastructure
as code with python it's the most common
language when we're coming dealing with
SRE environments so that I can manage
systems effectively well
on the Mainframe you may think about Rex
and JCL but forget about that you can
use Python to do all of what you need to
do on zos you can ignore those languages
and just build new things using Python
and if you have to you can call existing
Rex and JCL if you want to or you can do
it all in Python familiar it has full
capability to work with all of the
existing zos systems so that you can
configure your middleware do all the
automation necessary
and you get to take advantage of the
existing Hardware so you can use things
like the compression available on the
system through python so you're not
having to do something different or call
something different you have access to
the hardware itself capabilities from
your native python
and now when we think about this last
use case the CIO what does cios care
about money what is it going to cost me
to do this well
in the Z World we have the zip processor
the zip processor is running alongside
the general purpose processor and with
the zip you don't pay monthly license
charge so you're getting to do all this
additional processing without adding to
your bill and your bottom line so this
makes all of this work efficient
easy effective
and without costing any more
so hopefully it's clear that you love
Python and now you can love the
Mainframe with python since the
Mainframe is what runs the world
thanks for watching if you like this
video and would like to see more videos
like this just click like And subscribe